pas de fermeture et pas de suppressions
d'emplois disait ces banderoles le
premier souhait pas de fermeture sera
peut être exaucé monsieur qu'est wang un
industriel d'origine chinoise basée dans
les yvelines vient de déposer une offre
de reprise de la faïencerie de digoin
c'est une entreprise qu'il connaît avec
laquelle il était en affaires depuis
plusieurs années ce possible repreneur
mettre un million deux cent mille euros
sur la table et les représentants du
personnel estime que son projet tient la
route pour éviter de nouvelles
suppressions d'emplois en revanche ça
n'est pas gagné
le projet prévoit de passer de 62 à 42
salariés pour 14 postes
on ne pourra pas faire grand chose se
résigne les syndicats mais il espérant
sauver 6 et porter l'effectif à 48
personnes
c'est cette discussion qui a débuté avec
le repreneur et qui doit se clore le 21
mai le 24 le tribunal de commerce dira
s'il valide le projet si c'est le cas
monsieur qu'est wang prendra les
commandes de la faïencerie de digoin à
compter du premier jour